hey dr. Berg here in this short video
I'm going to talk about what is really
behind the stubborn weight issue if
you're struggling with losing weight you
need to know this
if you look around most people fall into
one of four body types
now sometimes they'll hold it in the
hips what that is
it's an estrogen problem it's too much
estrogen some people hold their weight
in the stomach as the protruding belly
that is a liver problem some people have
a sagging belly that is an adrenal
problem but it's too much cortisol
that's that stress hormone and then some
people hold the weight all over and not
in any one location that is a thyroid
problem but it's usually secondary to
higher estrogen or a liver so that's why
I didn't put it on there because that's
usually secondary now what you have to
realize is this weight is a symptom of
something else so why can't you lose
weight because you're treating the
weight directly there's always an
underlying cause let me show you okay so
now weight
especially stubborn weight is a symptom
of something so the question is why well
your metabolism is slow right you maybe
you thought your metabolism is slow and
it probably is but then what causes this
because what we don't want to do is we
do not want to treat the slow metabolism
directly with some pill or some berry or
stimulant because there's an underlying
reason why it's slow and it has to do
with hormones okay so we don't want to
treat the weight directly because that's
gonna just treat the symptom it's not
going to work you probably already tried
that we don't want to treat the
metabolism we want to strengthen the
hormones but now let me explain what I
mean by that so let me erase this and
I'll show you what I mean
okay so now there are six there are six
fat burning hormones that are triggered
by various things that you're going to
actually do eating exercise and things
like that and this has been a huge focus
probably on a lot of people they're
focusing in
to stimulate fat-burning but what they
don't know is this there are three
hormones that are dominating they're fat
making hormones so these are the burning
hormones of fat burning and these are
the fat making hormones so there's
hormones that make fat this one is
called insulin now this is what
explained all the low carb diets low
glycemic this is low sugar diets right
you probably know sugars bad for you and
you might have cravings if you have
cravings all that means is that you're
burning sugar you're not burning fat so
insulin is one of them in the presence
of a little bit of insulin these will be
blocked cancelled out it takes just a
little bit of bad thing to destroy a lot
of good stuff okay so we have insulin
and the next one is called cortisol
cortisol is a fat making hormone so in
the presence of too much cortisol and
that would be stress these again are
nullified cancelled out and lastly
estrogen so in the presence of too much
estrogen these are canceled out so what
I want to do is expand your concept of
not just focusing on what to do but
eliminating these three counter hormones
and there's various ways that we can do
that using eating plans certain
techniques and even nutritional
techniques okay so that would be an
interesting concept because if this is
too high you're going to gain weight in
the hip and this is too high you'll gain
weight in the belly I don't care how
many sit-ups you do I don't care how
many hours of exercise you do it's not
going to work